bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin 1 sur rt
france on est on est heureux d'avoir un
sénateur et un député pour nous parler
de ce qui se passe en ce moment c'est
très c'est très dur on l'a entendue à
l'assemblée il ya eu des débats assez
houleux 1-1 article d'eau qui est passé
à une voix près c'est quand même assez
court hubert julien laferrière est ce
que vous y étiez à l'assemblée
oui j étais à l'assemblée
si vous voulez on est on est quand même
dans une situation depuis un an et demi
où le parlement est relativement
méprisée dans cette histoire
j ai l'arctique dépassé vous après il la
loi elle-même est passé à sa petite voix
à des petites voix et si vous voulez il
y a évidemment dans ce projet de loi
c'est beaucoup de gens qui se sont
opposés
à cette loi à la fois ne nie pas
évidemment la gravité de la pandémie ni
une ni le fait qu'il faille dans des
situations exceptionnelles
priver les français de certaines
libertés pour des raisons sanitaires
mais là on est dans une situation à la
fois démocratique
sur le plan si vous voulez de la
longévité de la mesure proposée
sur le fait qu'ils aient pas de clause
de revoyure avec les représentants du
peuple mais surtout on est depuis
maintenant plus d'un an dans un
dispositif d'hyper présidentialisation
est totalement exacerbée et devait de
mépris du parlement et à chaque fois
qu'on dit ça au gouvernement on nous dit
mais regardez ça fait maintenant sept ou
huit fois qu'on débat avec le parlement
le problème c'est qu'on est dans une
situation où aucune démocrate que
qu'aucune démocratie parlementaire
n'accepterait où le président de la
république annonce ce qui va se passer
avant même que le départ parlement et
puis ensuite
ensuite évidemment comme il sait qu'il a
une majorité à l'assemblée nationale eh
bien dans les jours qui suivent en en
une soirée ou en deux jours
effectivement on fait passer la mesure
mais le seul le seul fait que le
président de la république annonce à la
télévision
ce que
ce à quoi les français vont être
confrontés avant même d'avoir saisi
parlement c'est absolument incroyable et
bien ça ne se passerait dans aucune
autre démocratie parlementaire ouais
vous parliez de la majorité acquise au
président la république à six mois
d'élections ce qui est hélas c'était
juste et est justement alors ça quand
même failli pas être le cas et
christophe castaner le chef du groupe la
république en marche était furieux il a
même vu demander à ses troupes de
revenir sur les bancs de l'assemblée
puisqu'il y avait on a noté aussi un
taux d'absentéisme c'est énorme pour une
loi très très importante pour les
français un commentaire maxime st michel
calvet
oui je comprends que te faire
effectivement que
[Musique]
excusez moi qui j'étais sur autre chose
je
veux continuer parce que ça fait déjà
depuis
2015 que des projets de loi qui prive
les français de liberté se succèdent dès
lors il ya eu certes des attentats au
départ maintenant la situation sanitaire
mais ceci étant cette fois des
situations qui sont relativement
liberticide technip et le respect de
liberté en quelque sorte et ben je
comprends qu'il ya effectivement
beaucoup de parlementaires s'interrogent
et il faut que le parlement cantonal
vient d'être dissout feu rose c'est à
dire celui d'analysé l'éleveur qu'il
faut pas prendre et de pouvoir s'assurer
que cela ne prend pas les libertés
fondamentales de nos principes et qui se
terrent antilles parce qu'ils étaient
dans la constitution expliquez-nous
pourquoi ne pas vouloir aller au delà du
28 février
tout simplement parce que le parlement
soit réuni jusqu'à la fin février donc
on voit bien qu'il est possible le texte
qui est soumis ici a été de perdre et
des ministres de 13 2 octobre aura bien
qu'en deux semaines on peut examiné au
parlement à theix voilà deux semaines
que ce n'est pas très long donc c'est
l'époque qui permet aussi aux
parlementaires de s'assurer que le
contexte dans lequel tout cela sur place
et
fois au respect des libertés
individuelles et
certaines mesures de des dispositions à
prendre pour éviter la propagation du
virus et donc de se tenir en va jusqu'à
une date extrêmement et body en
l'occurrence de 31 juillet
2020 10 voire même le 31 octobre 2022
dans le texte pour ce qu'ils voient un
choix des étudiants pas le sens
extrêmement lointain est
pas approprié si vous voulez est ce
qu'ils les actions présidentiel au
milieu en plus on va garder la lecture
présidence pas pas arrêté là par moments
on ne va pas empêcher de prendre de
décision on va parler de ce que vous
dites avec eux ceux de cette crise
sanitaire c'est s'ils sont ces états
d'exception liées au terrorisme
également un coup d'état permanent
dénoncé peu une fois n'est pas coutume
par le journaliste de libération de
journalistes europe jean quatremer
regarder ce qu'il dit n'a pas mâché ses
mots en tout cas sur le mandat d'
emmanuel macron
le quinquennat d'emmanuel macron restera
dans l'histoire comme celui de l'état
d'exception permanent cette mise à
disposition de l'état de droit et des
libertés publiques au profit du seul
exécutif avec pour corollaire
l'affaiblissement des contre-pouvoirs
les berjalliens et laferrière est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ce constat
oui je suis assez d'accord et c'est
assez surprenant parce que effectivement
en 2017
d'ailleurs je l'assumé a jamais fait
partie des personnes qui avaient été
séduits par parallèle à la candidature
des mêmes mâcon c'était plutôt un
candidat justement de quitter ford et
les libertés oui et qu'ils défendent à
la fois les libertés sur le plan
économique mais aussi sur le sur le plan
sociétal et on est petit à petit on a
dérivé un pouvoir qui est toujours pour
les libertés sur le plan économique mais
qui sur le plan sociétal en fait est de
plus en plus autoritaire et
effectivement qui petit à petit prive
les français de certaines libertés au
nom de la sécurité au nom de la sécurité
sanitaire et on a une double dérive
sénat
une dérive à la fois liberticide et est
aussi une dérive démocratique au sens de
non respect du parlement des
représentants du peuple des contre
pouvoirs en général c'est ça qui était
assez inquiétant dans ce pouvoir witch
et ceux qui disent à jean quatremer mois
notre collègue avec noé d'autres ne sont
ni des complotistes ni des gens qui
confondent g ctive mans le pouvoir en
france et les dictatures en amérique
latine ou ailleurs moi j'ai jamais dit
que l'on était en dictature mais on a
effectivement une dérive si vous voulez
anti liberté que qui n'était pas du tout
la marque de fabrique de même un conte
lorsqu'il s'est présenté en 2017 et
j'insiste vraiment sur le moi moi je
suis parlementaire que depuis 2002 6 17
mai j'ai discuté avec des collègues qui
sont parlement car depuis longtemps que
moi puis d'autres moix évidemment la
vème république déjà restreint les
droits du parlement mais on me dit on
n'a jamais atteint un tel niveau de
mépris du parlement
parlement enfin l'assemblée nationale en
tout cas pour ma part chambre
d'enregistrement des décisions d'un
pouvoir exécutif qui se croient tout
permis et ça c'est quand même un vrai
problème sur lequel il faut attirer
l'attention de nos concitoyens les
députés sénateurs sont les représentants
du peuple c'est comme ça que fonctionne
la démocratie et
ses représentants du top ne peut pas
être considérée comme une chambre
d'enregistrement des décisions d'un
pouvoir qui estimerait avoir le soutien
du peuple avec lui michel calvet est ce
que le sénat aujourd'hui finalement est
le seul recours de contre-pouvoir à
l'exécutif je vous propose de regarder
ce qu'a dit florian philippot le l'icône
l'est des antilles passe évidemment il
nous interpelle regarder
en juillet les sénateurs avait déploré
avoir voté le pass sanitaire avec un
pistolet sur la tempe mouais ils peuvent
parfaitement rattrapé sa jeudi en
refusant de voter sa prolongation ainsi
que la levée du secret médical à l'école
pour michel calvet est ce que ça va s
que les sénateurs vont faire bloc cette
fois
il faut pas faire bloc les sénateurs
puisqu'il ya toujours des collègues qui
sont favorables à cette disposition
proposée par le gouvernement ceci étant
une majorité de sénateurs câble est
préoccupé par
cette prolongation à très long terme de
l'état d'urgence par le fait aussi que
par des ordonnances et bien en plus
adapté à sa peau nombre de dispositions
nous nous préférerions de l'avons
toujours dit au sénat que cette
disposition faut examiner dans l'église
cette étude est que vale parlement
puisse effectivement s'est positionné
sur les réceptions de sa culture de vie
qui sont imposés à nos concitoyens
toujours que ne le découvrir par les
médias la décision qui est prise par le
gouvernement reste en fuite et qui en
fit est proscrite par les hormones
entrerait
dans la vème république il faut quand
même que le gouvernement a la
possibilité dans le coup avant
maintenance mais à notre sens ça doit
rester extrêmement limitée et n'est pas
normal que ce recours aux ordonnances
aujourd'hui si important il faut que
reviennent à des choses extrêmement
simple où les parlementaires faux-pas
capacité d'analysé et de décider des
situations c'est à dire les mesures à
prendre je prends un exemple on peut
aller dans les librairies par exemple on
peut parler dans les bibliothèques sans
le pass solitaire qu'est ce qui explique
sa copine à une manifestation
qui comprend son masque au moment de la
manifestation appelée moment du pot
derrière maintenant obligés d'enlever
son masque on arrive à des situations il
faut pas fuir pour illustrer que par des
efforts
futile mais ceci étant ce soir et des
sujets qui concernent la vie de tout le
monde et sur lesquelles il faut qu'au
fond de moi je crois beaucoup en la
responsabilité des uns et des autres et
donc il est nécessaire que
proportionne plus les contraintes pour
imposer une berge julien-laferrière vous
êtes d'accord avec ça 6 à 6 à bloquer ou
au cenasa repassera derrière par
ordonnance
à 6-6 a bloqué au sénat il ya hélas oui
et non pour lesquels l assemblée
nationale à l dernier mot puisque c'est
la constitution mais sur les ordonnances
ou quand il ya tout à fait raison
depuis depuis maintenant bientôt deux
ans on légifère parents de lens il faut
rappeler ce que c'est qu'une audience
c'est la possibilité pour le
gouvernement de prendre part par décret
par voie réglementaire des décisions qui
relèvent normalement du domaine de la
loi c'est-à-dire des représentants du
peuple
est là et c'est évidemment une exception
normalement règle et l'exception devient
devient la règle donc ça c'est c'est un
vrai problème et ça est normalement
quand on donc quand le gouvernement
prend ses mesures par ordonnance bon
alors après il ya effectivement une loi
d'habilitation
mais moi j'ai souvenir de comment ça
s'est passé au début du confinement
tout tout tout une série de décisions
qui tu es vraiment privative de liberté
encore une fois que à l'époque ne sont
pas forcément contre le fait de priver
les français de liberté dans un tel
contexte sanitaire ça c'est ça c'est un
autre débat mais le fait si vous les
deux privée de liberté comme ça les
français et de ne même pas revenir au
parlement pour régulièrement pour en
débattre pour pourvoir pour point qu'on
existe pour discuter de où on va de
quels sont les est-ce qu'il ya une
propos l acquisition la proportionnalité
des privations de liberté
risque pour les fondements scientifiques
aussi sont plus en plus écartée
qui a pas forcément de concertation au
niveau du conseil scientifique pour
prendre de telles décisions sur la
prolongation vue alors bon là on est
effectivement huisseau sur le projet de
bouaké l'actuel c'est évidemment un vrai
sujet et puis le à la situation
pandémique ne le justifie pas forcément
le conseil scientifique a émis des
doutes et puis et puis beaucoup d'autres
d'autorités sanitaires d'ailleurs qu'on
a ou qu'on a oublié au départ puisqu'on
a on a créé un conseil scientifique
effectivement haddock alors qu'il y
avait évidemment des autorités
sanitaires déjà des jeux qui déjà
existantes qui pourrait concerner le
gouvernement et aujourd'hui on a on a
quand même un pouvoir qui prend des
décisions encore une fois et qui se
targue d'avoir le soutien les français
et qui demande au parlement
peut-être une chambre d'enregistrement
fond peau pour les enterrer ils ont
terminé je chante avec juste une chose
rires
je crains que en voulant diviser les
français ont le fassent de façon
involontaire en six ans de façon à une
majorité avec nous sadi mise et on va
faire bloc avec cette majorité qui me
soutient ça c'est pas bon pour la france
et peut-être pas bon non plus à six mois
d'élections présidentielles merci
beaucoup on n'a plus le temps
malheureusement merci hubert julien
laferrière et merci à vous michel calvet
d'avoir participé à ce débat ce matin en
direct sur arte france